if people ask me why I workout which
they occasionally do I often tell them
it's because if I ever met Batman that
way we'd have something in common
so I love superhero comics and films and
stuff and I think that's one of the
reasons that I got into working out when
I was younger you find a lot of people
who are really into comments they they
read them a lot but they they don't try
and emulate them and I always thought
why wouldn't you want to try and be more
like Batman Batman's a particularly good
one to emulate because he's human
whenever I've tried to transform into a
Lory like Optimus Prime
it has met with disappointment and
frustration so I've done some research
into how Batman trains I looked at a
book called the Batman files which
actually details a workout that Batman
might use in this workout we see that he
essentially does something I looked a
little bit like CrossFit so there's a
surprise he does lots of kettlebell
swings lots of ring dips lots of cardio
mixed with compound lifts and also he
does an insane amount that just
physically would not be possible the
only way I can imagine that Batman would
be capable of doing that amount without
completely dying would be to use
steroids and I think that Batman
probably would use they always in fact I
think it happened in one comic that was
maybe called venom or something like
that I think he did use a steroid or
something like that
and yeah he probably would because he's
not going to care about the health
effects all he cares about is killing
bad guys like Batman is supposed to be
nuts that's kind of the whole point so
yeah he probably used to steroids we're
not going to go quite as far as him
because you'd end up breaking a spine
and collapsing in an overtrained met
Batman probably would train in a kind of
more compound that kind of more Sealy
mixed with strength training method if
we look at this list we also see things
like lots of running for endurance lots
of bouldering that's climbing short
distances without a rope so that you can
fall and probably not die I'm frozen
free Soleil which is climbing high
distances of that rate he does a lot of
heavy bag work there's a lot of martial
arts what martial arts really think
maybe do min Jitsu this is pretty much
non-existent anymore but you do get some
classes I'm not sure not sure how
authentic they are in the region
Christopher Nolan films he uses a
martial art called the KC fighting
method this is the martial art that they
referred to when when choreographing the
fight scenes because it's all about
close quarters fighting multiple
opponents using this around these elbows
knees quick takedown around knock him
out headbutt him why not why do a triple
spin kick double loop you know why not
just knock him out we were looking for
something that when Batman for a punch
or a kick they went through the person
like a Raging Bull Batman would also
supplement all this training with like
ambidexterity training and grip training
and brain training and nootropics and I
talked about all that on my website
where I've done it a more in-depth
version of this but as Marc so the
objective here is to create a workout
that full body can be done at home with
equipment that you might have and it
will build some of the abilities that
Batman might covet like strength to
weight ratio compound strength explosive
power cardio endurance you name it grip
strength etc all stuff useful for
fighting bad guys add this to your
workout once a week and you will be a
more awesome crime fighter maybe
possibly perhaps okay so are you ready
the home Batman workout
okay so we're going to start with some
dumbbell clean and presses this is a
pretty safe one because it's actually in
the Batman files except he uses a
barbell most people can't fit a barbell
in their home though we're going to go
three sets to failure twelve repetitions
each we're going for power here next up
we're going to mix up with some
one-armed kettlebell clean and presses
this is great because you're doing it on
just one side of your body that means
you have to use your obliques to
stabilize yourself and after we pre
exhausted with those clean and presses
this should be nice and challenging
through even more good for the legs the
shoulders and for the upper pecs and
triceps and everything else again
perform for three sets of twelve to
failure
you
okay now we're going to do some neutral
grip pull-ups the only difference here
is we're going to use a rope hanging
over the bar this is excellent for the
grip really hurts your hands as you can
see here me showing you very nasty and
red once you can do no more of those you
can just go onto regular neutral grip
pull-ups or you know chin-ups or
pull-ups Batman doesn't mind what you do
you might want to do chin-ups if you
want to involve your biceps a little bit
more vary the speed as I'm doing here do
some fast ones do some slow ones this
way you'll train the fast and slow
twitch muscle fibers you'll train muscle
endurance and muscle power this is the
basic concept of power building which
maybe is something Batman likes I'll
have to ask it keeping the legs up there
just to involve the ABS in the core a
little bit so you're using these two as
a drop set do as many of the grippy ones
on the rope as you can and as soon as
you can you know more switch straight to
the regular ones using the bar next up
ring dips this is another pretty safe
one we know the Batman does these two
because again it's mentioned in the
Batman files which I think he wrote
himself actually ring dips are great for
their pecs for the triceps and they are
very good for the core because you have
to use the core stabilizing muscles in
the Batman files actually says do ring
dick training mainly muscle ups welder
obviously this is because Batman does
parkour and he obviously wants to be
able to do muscle ups onto buildings
mounts on these three sets to failure
again Batman does a million with an
elephant on his back work up to that now
come the spider-man crawls a competitor
to Batman when it comes to agile
superheroes
spider-man crawls are cool because
they're contralateral that means that
they involve a lot coordination between
the left and the right hand side of your
body this is great for the central
nervous system
general proprioception balance that sort
of thing core this is also a great
isometric hold
for the pecs and it works the abs in the
core
well particularly the transverse
abdominus which helps Batman to not
break his back when he's squatting and
deadlifting you can do this for reps but
actually it's quite interesting if you
do it the time instead so set yourself a
good goal something like a one-minute
accruals rest for ten seconds and go
again
now wall pushes this is just a static
contraction I'm trying to push down the
wall hold it for 10 seconds let go
repeat do this for I don't know 20 sets
just until your head feels a little bit
lightheaded static contraction is
excellent building pure power we're
going to finish up with kettlebell
swings that's another one that's
actually specifically mentioned in the
Batman files this is our finisher so
this is for fat burning and cardio we're
going to use the Tabata protocol so that
means we're going to do eight intervals
of 20 seconds going as fast as you can
followed by 10 seconds of rest this is a
great way to add the cardio onto the end
of a workout burn off calories increase
your vo2 max and one of that anwer but
into the workout you are doing
they've been there
you